now this is something you don't hear
very often at the moment the expansion
of a newspaper and one that's still
printed physically at that
the new european which emerged following
the pro-brexit result in the 2016
referendum in the uk
is expanding appropriately enough across
europe and today we can reveal that the
newspaper has been bought by its
management
from the uk regional newspaper publisher
archanes
well gavin o'reilly the media investor
and the ex-chief executive of
independent news and media is the new
executive chairman
and i'm very pleased to say he joins me
now gavin o'reilly welcome
to you if this newspaper has such
fantastic prospects why are archant
selling it
well they've just been bought by private
equity themselves
and um i they are arjun or regional
publishers up in in norwich and great
regional publishers at that
um and i think this this particular
brand didn't sit with their portfolio
so the opportunity arose matt kelly who
founded the paper uh four and a half
years ago uh
negotiated with arch and brought me in
and
we managed to do what i think is a good
deal for arch and a good deal for
ourselves and we got some
really great investors on board
um lionel barber former ex uh
editor of the ft and uh mark thompson
amongst uh other tech investors as well
and what made you want to get involved
well i've been in publishing all my life
um i've known that for years i've always
really respected what he had done with
the european i mean
it started obviously in the wake of the
brexit vote uh four and a half years ago
and uh it was only supposed to be a
title that was in existence for
four weeks and four and a half years
later we're still here
uh and that's all because of matt his
great tenacity
his great vision for the title but it's
a title that i don't think has ever
really
fully exploited its true potential and
uh
you know that is gonna now be made
possible by the uh
the investment uh that we're going to
make and expansion
across europe expansion of our digital
and print products and
print is much derided uh i know but it
still is a very very
uh very relevant medium and uh
ultimately it'd be for our readers to
decide i mean we're agnostic as to
platform it'll be for our readers to
decide
how they wish to consume the new
european
a lot of critics would say well hang on
the new european uh
supported remain that cause is now lost
what are you arguing for now
well i don't necessarily think that
we're necessarily arguing for anything i
mean it's right it was the paper of the
48
if you want to call it that but i think
the new european is perhaps
even more relevant than it was in those
debates four years ago
um we're now out of uh the european
community but it still is
the most relevant uh trading block for
the united kingdom
uh a lot of promises have been made as
to how brexit is supposed to manifest
itself which has
real life impacts on people and i think
you know the new european will be
holding the brexiteers to account but
equally it'll be holding
uh the europeans whether it's the eu or
the parliament
uh to account as well because certainly
the european has always been
consistently advocating for
progressive change and reform within
europe and that's still required
will the title be campaigning for the uk
to rejoin the eu
well look i think that uh that debate is
uh
has has been lost for now i mean
certainly i don't
see any immediate prospect of the uk
returning
uh to europe in the uh in the immediate
uh uh term
but who knows it may happen in the
future uh but i think quite independent
of that i think the
the new european certainly has an
important
uh voice or projects an important voice
for british nationals but also for
europeans trying to understand
what is happening or what is not
happening in the uk
visit the its relationship with europe
briefly is the title profitable at the
moment
yeah marginally profitable um i mean i
don't think we're going to be
uh making millions this year uh we've
got a pretty aggressive investment plan
um and uh you know we're going to be
making those investments this year
that'll have a short-term impact on
profitability but but certainly we have
a
fairly vigorous and rigorous uh
investment case going forward
all right gavin o'reilly we have to
leave it there i'm afraid very good to
talk to you this morning thanks for
joining me
thanks ian thank you